for my perfect picnic lunch a grated
carrot cumin and orange salad and a
spectacular sandwich based on a classic
from southern France
pan bania this is a picnic sandwich with
a twist but the secret is in the layers
to make a delicious
Chaffin are a puree of olives seasoned
with capers and anchovies a nice
tablespoon of extra-virgin olive oil
garlic in a little teaspoon of red wine
vinegar I just sort of zapped that the
flavor quite like leaving nice and
chunky taste better and feels richer
almost a spreading smooth layer of
Tappin art rather than using both off
now to prepare my first Mediterranean
sandwich filling I want nice long slices
of courgette courgette can be a land
vegetable seasoning nicely on that grill
is nice and hot a tablespoon of olive
oil
the more color you put on those
courgette the more flavor while my
griddle courgette it's cool I can
prepare the bread this is a stunning
beautiful country loaf but we're not
going to slice it and we're going to cut
the top off because I'm sending a picnic
sandwich basket and then an inch from
the crust and go around scoop out a nice
large Hollow
don't waste it but put that out dry it
makes the most amazing vocal the secret
now is filling that cavity with all
those wonderful Mediterranean flavors
and we'll leave them to sort of sit and
marinate lightly season the inside of
those drizzle of olive oil lime for that
wonderful seminar and spread it
generously because the groundwork it
starts to set the tone the flavors that
were incorporating traditionally the
main protein in pan bagnat would be tuna
I'm sticking with the med but replacing
the fish with some of my family's
Italian favorites Parma ham and start
lining my sandwich from the center every
time I add another ingredient which is
another stunning layer of texture and
flavor but what I'm thinking about what
actually complements the next layer
mozzarella little spoon of my tapanade
we've got the most amazing the QI pepper
has got a nice smoky barbecue flavor
open them up and lay them on top next
layer wonderful grilled courgette
[Music]
top of that combust tomato concentrated
but really chewy and delicious each time
lightly press them down creamy
mozzarella again and finally peppers
push that down not to some hole in fill
that with your tap a knife almost like a
little glue now lid on to seal all that
flavor in there I'm not only Charles
well but actually tastes delicious
that is one stunning picnic sandwich
next a brilliant picnic salad as just as
robust as your pan Bunyan hat and cumin
and orange perfect ombre nation again
travels brilliantly doesn't will doesn't
disintegrate always death squeeze the
orange over sunflower seeds a bit of
crunch in there pumpkin seeds again
another bike next kind of spice toasted
cumin seeds ground with the help of a
little coarse sea salt
[Music]
you know it's fine powder now for the
dressing table spoon Dijon mustard
tablespoon of honey 1/2 a tablespoon of
white wine vinegar and then a nice glug
of olive oil fresh mint and coriander
the minute you start picking fresh herb
all that flavor comes out mix delicious
vinegar mix that int given our dressing
binded together excite the palate not
drown it if it was a leaf salad then
I'll take the dressing separately but
because this is a robust root vegetable
it can sustain being dressed now and
eaten in two hours time sweet spicy
fragrance companies ask much more from a
carrot any beautiful
[Music]
differing your guessed thing that you're
cutting up a delicious country loaf
whether that may be Wow and who would
not want to join you on a picnic with a
sandwich like that my ultimate picnic
lunch to surprise and impress pan bania
bursting with rich sunshine flavors and
serve with a refreshing leave zinging
carrot cumin and orange salad
[Music]
you
[Music]